hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar time
resolved
stead microscopy i'm christy jewel of
labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths
and sponsored by leica microsystems
for more information on our sponsor
please visit leica microsystems.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you like
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation you can click
on the support tab
or report your problem by using the ask
a question box
on the far left side of your screen you
can also share this webinar on your
personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab and
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event
additionally today's presentation is
educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
after viewing the presentation just
click on the continuing education
credits tab
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
and now to our speaker presenting live
from genoa italy
i would like to introduce dr giuseppe
richard domini
senior researcher tenured principal
investigator
at the italian institute of technology
for a complete biography on dr
victor domini please visit the biography
tab
at the top of your screen dr victor
domini welcome
you may now begin your presentation
good morning and or good afternoon
depending where are you
uh i'm disappointed from
the pi of the molecular microscopy and
spectroscopy laboratory
at the institute or italian technology
in in general
and today i would like to talk about
time resources that microscopic
and i'm really grateful to people from
leica and also to christy to give me
this
opportunity to to talk about this topic
because this topic
represents somehow the last almost 10
years
of my research into the unto the uh
microscopy um i'm
from uh from the ground i'm a computer
scientist
and ten years ago i just finished my
my phd thesis and
i started to to to move in a lab of fifa
and at that time i don't be
uh so much keno into microscopy i was
mainly working image microscopy
and when i read this sentence in a
in a review uh i was quite surprised so
uh when i read that more than 80 percent
of the image of a cell in a textbook or
in the journal in a scientific journal
are you going to acquire with the
fluorescent microscope
i was really really astonished but
slowly i
understand read the reason why not that
and
that's briefly i most of you maybe
already know
but i want to wrap up the main reason of
this great success of
optical microscope in particular
fluorescent microscopy
so clearly one of the most important
feature of
fluorescent microscopy its ability to
observe
life so it can be used for recording
uh lifestyle like tissue
up to organizing because since we are
using light and light is not
so much perturbative at least when
you're using
low dose of light it's extremely
powerful technique to really understand
deeply all phenomena of life
and another very important
characteristic especially for people
that work in computer science
is that a microscopy provide you so many
information because it's a
multi-dimensionality technique
so maybe the most classical
multi-dimensionality
is the the fact that a microscope can
provide you three-dimensional
imaging so it's not only provide you
flat
measurement but we know that life of
course in 3d
and microspay can investigate through
this phenomenon
then microscopy can be combined somehow
with spectroscopy classic examples again
a multicolor image you can label
different
structure inside your sample like in
this example which has
actin mitochondria and nucleus stain
with different color with this molecule
with this fluorophore
to really understand the cooperation
between them
between the different uh biomolecule
inside the cell inside the systems and
the sample that you wanted to
investigate and another extremely
important
dimension in microscopy is the time so
since
microscope is a non-invasive technique i
can observe
my biological sample across the time
another extremely important
characteristic of fluorescent microscopy
is that it's very versatile and
technique
so the complexity of the system is not
so
huge and most important the sample
preparation is rather pretty easy
and when you feed in front of a
microscope probably in a couple of days
you will be autonomous and you can
perform your your measurement
and then crazy is clearly is the sort of
artifact-free system
you immediately get out the knees that
you need and you can analyze
it another important property is the
spatial resolution so with an optical
microscope
you have decent resolution to
investigate
the most puzzling phenomena of life but
if i ask to you it's really enough this
resolution
uh the resolution of the conventional
optical microsoft a conventional
comfortable microscope
is really enough to answer to all your
bio questions
i guess that the answer we know since we
are in the air of super resolution
is that no clearly no because the the
let's say the distraction barrier this
physical phenomenon
doesn't allow you to distinguish
features to have a resolution a special
resolution
that is roughly 200 millimeter that
depends by the wavelength of light that
are using
and by the numerical object objective
that they are using
in particular is lambda over 2 and a
when n a is a numerical pressure of the
objective lenses
but if i have to just say number if you
since we are using visible wavelength
and anyway the numerical platform so
your objective lens is
limited then this value is around 20
nanometer
but most of the important phenomena
occur at a much smaller level
at the molecular level most of your
macromolecule that you are interested in
your rna
or other protein or other molecular
machine are much below this one
nanometer
so it's clear that if an optical
microscope with the only property that i
should as i told you before
the possibility to investigate life the
multi-dimensionality diversity
can be somehow modified in order to
improve the resolution below this
this diffraction limit is 200 nanometers
you will get
enormous benefit somehow what like
is to get the same characteristic of an
optical microscope
but to reach almost the resolution of an
electron microscope
so nowadays we know that thanks to these
three gentlemen eric mexic stephanelle
and william warner
now we can achieve such a molecular
scale resolution
thanks to the super resolution technique
or nanoscopy technique
and so now we have access to the scale
that previously was achievable only by
electron microscopy but still preserving
all the features of a fluorescent or
optical microscope or
at least most of this feature and during
this talk i will show also some trick
out effectively
preserve this this kind of feature
especially the possibility to do
live live imaging um
okay one probably the first
and one of the most powerful uh super
resolution technique
uh that nowadays we can find in many
in many laboratories and it can be
really used to to the biological
community
instead microscopy so that microscopy
was invented
in 94 and 3 nowadays most of the as i
told you before
most of the lab was invented by stefano
and most of the lab as this this
microscopy technique
on board and so the topic of this
of this talk is about my class we saw i
would like to take
first a chance to introduce this
this technique but to introduce this
technique i need before to introduce
some basic
concept of florescent that maybe most of
you already know but just to cover
um the majority of the audience i would
like to recap
uh then at least the basic
uh knowledge of fluorescence
so you perfectly know that fluorescence
is the phenomenon by which if i radiate
a molecule fluorophore with a specific
wavelength
the molecule will emit after a few uh
after almost simultaneously uh another
uh light with a slightly different color
so that's more or less what we know
about what is the basic knowledge of
fluorescence
but let's go a little bit deeper and in
particular let's understand the temporal
characteristic of the fluorescence
so the first things that the first
step in the fluorescence process is the
absorption
of a molecule of a particular photon
so here i depicted the molecule in the
in the most
uh in a two state as a two-state system
and here there is the jobless diameter
representation
so when the molecule naturally is in the
ground state
as zero then it can if we shine light on
it
of a particular wavelength and the
wavelength depend by its absorption
spectrum that is depicted here
then the molecule what is doing is
absorbing this photo in a very
in a very very very fast manner in the
order of 70 seconds
and then move to higher excited state
s1 when is this higher excited space
then it will stay
in this in the higher vibrational states
of the of the uh
of the of the excise state for a very
short period
in their order of picosecond and then we
relax to the lower level of the
vibrational states
after spending and that's a very
important
uh property few nanoseconds into the
excited states and that's what we call
the exciting state lifetime of the
molecule
it will emit a photon with a different
wavelength
in the emission off of my fluorophore
and in particular the the wavelength of
emission will be
shifted towards longer wavelength
because there is a loss of energy
and important this again
this transition will occur again at the
femtosecond
uh in the central second scale but what
isn't very important is that the
lifetime of the molecule to the excited
state
it's in the order of nanoseconds so
another important
uh things that we have to know to
understand stimulated venetian is
exactly
uh to understand immediate emission
microscope is exactly the stimulated
emission phenomena
so in physics we know that when there is
a phenomenon
usually there is always a contrary
phenomenon so if it's possible to
excite the molecule by light it's also
possible to add the excise
the same molecule by light and that's
exactly
the stimulated emission process so what
does it mean that when the molecules
into the excited states
it's possible to use another photon
in this case the redshifted photo with
respect to the
to the to the emission of the
fluorophore to the
excite the fluorophore from the ground
from the excited state
to the ground state in this case what
will happen
is that we will use another photon that
from now will cause stimulated emission
photon
to the excite the molecule from the
excited state to the ground state
and what will happen that we will have a
second photon
identical to the stimulated emission
photon
because we need to release energy from
from the molecule
so but it's clear that this second
photon is
identical to the photon that's used to
induce stimulated emission
and in particular is as the very same
wavelength
so this means that we can easily select
the stimulus we can easily select the
spontaneous
emission the fluorescent emission
depicted here in green
from the stimulated venetian that will
be we'll have a red color we'll have a
color
identical to the laser to the light that
we use to induce stimulated emissions
so now that we have in clear in mind the
phenomenon of fluorescence the temporal
scale of
this phenomena and the fact that it's
possible to
say to excite a molecule but also to the
excited molecule
by light so let's try to understand the
stimulated emission depression
microscopy
so to understand the principle of
stimulated emission depression
microscopy it
is important to understand which is the
problem
of destruction in a conventional
confocal microscope so
let's take this as a phantom example so
here we have the log of our institute
the iit
the yellow the dots represent the
molecules in my sample
so we if we use a laser and we shine
this laser
we focus the laser by the objective lens
in a particular position of my sample
what will happen that all the molecule
inside the sample
will be excited and
what will happen is that almost
instantaneously
after three nanoseconds because i told
you that the excited state lifetime of
the monitor is the order of nano cycle
they will emit fluorescence photon
this fluorescent photon is collected by
the same objective length
and this cool end is imagined to the
detector
that is recording a single density value
that is
then stored into the computer but what
is very important that since
light from the molecule is emitted
simultaneously
all the molecule all the light from this
molecule will be recorded simultaneously
thereby
all these molecules inside the
excitation volume and now i depicted
them in yellow to represent the
excitation step
they will emit light simultaneously and
they fuse all together
them density so there is no way to
separate the molecule in the dot of a
from the other molecule in the other
part of my
phantom in since we are in a scanning
microscope what we left and then is that
we will shift our excitation volume to
another region
and we will record again the
fluorescence light it's very important
that we are recording
in this case the fluorescent that is in
a red in a green
regime if we scan
across all the sample we end up in a
digital images
that is here on the right side which is
a blur
representation of my real object
simply because when excite when i
shine light in a region of my sample
that as i told you due to the reflection
is in the range of 20 nanometers
all these 200 all the molecule within
this 200 nanometer
we see we shine like simultaneously that
is recorded by the detector
and then scanning the beam across the
sample i will form the images
thereby there will be no way to separate
the light that is coming from molecules
that are closer than the diffraction
limited then are closer than this 200
nanometer
here it's a real example while this one
is a phantom that's a real example
again not of the of a sort of phantom
sample because these are uh
40 nanometers first and this as you can
see it's a blurred version of this
of this beads but let's see now as i
told you before
now what what is the the major problem
is that all the molecules
shine light simultaneously but if you
remember
at the beginning i told you that there
is a way to silence the molecule to some
way
to prevent a molecule to emit
fluorescent to emit a spontaneous photon
and thereby to quench the molecule to
silence the molecule to switch off a
molecule
that is by stimulated emissions so by
stimulated emission i have a way that i
can
somehow switch on a molecule and prevent
to emit fluorescence that's not enough
to get
stimulated to get super resolution and
patience to get super resolution by
stimulating emission depression
microscopy
so what i have to do for them is to
switch off the molecule in a particular
position in a particular spatial
position so as you can see here
so what i have to do i don't have to
switch on
switch off the fluorophore everywhere
but i have to switch off the fluorophore
only in the periphery of my excitation
volume
and to do that i have to engineering my
laser the focus of the laser that is
used
to quench to silence the for the
fluorophore
so now i will call this laser step beam
and to shape to switch off the
fluorophore
only in the periphery i have to
engineering the stair beam
as a doughnut shape with zero intensity
pointed to the middle
and the high intensity extend the step
intensity
into the periphery if i'm able to do
this trick what will happen is that i
will
only make fluorescence the molecules
that are in the center
of the of the excitation volume
while all the other molecules in the
periphery
will be switched off as you can see for
example for this graph so
when i from this from this picture again
after scanning the beam across the
sample
i will end up with any digital images
that is that with an improved resolution
as you can see compare this
to two pixels just because i
i was able to quench the fluorescence
the fluorescent molecule
into the periphery of my excitation
volume of the scanning microscope
but it's clear that the diffraction
is still there so that means that this
the
the the shape of my doughnut
stud beam is still ruled by distraction
and thereby i cannot let's say make an
old that is
very small in order to quench all the
molecule in the periphery and
every fluorescent only the one in the
very center
but what they can do is to saturate the
stimulated emission transition
so what does it mean i can increase the
intensity
of the stat beam in order to have
enough intensity also very close to the
zero intensity point
of my step beam and there is this means
in the very center
of my excitation volume in order to
quench
even more the molecule in the periphery
here on this side you can see the graph
of what we call depletion curve they
tell you the probability of fluorescent
as a function of the intensity of the
stud beam higher is the intensity of the
step beam
lower is the probability that the
molecule fluoresces that the molecule
decay
by spontaneous emissions very important
the molecule is still after the excited
and after the stimulating photon
will emit a photon but this photon has
the same the very same wavelength of the
stimulated emission photon
thereby if we use the proper filter that
select
the the light only in this region we can
collect
only the the spontaneous emission the
first and discard the stimulated
emission
for stimulated photo so
if we increase even more so what we left
the intensity of the step beam
so now that only the molecule that is in
the very
center of the step beam can
emit photon why all the other one are
switched off
so that means that instead microscope
what we can do we can tune the
resolution of my microscope
by simply increasing the intensity of
the study and we'll follow these rules
so we are the new terms in our
in our resolution and in particular in
the size of detection volume
that depend by the intensity of the
spelling highest intensity of the set
beam
higher is the resolution of my sister as
you can see from this phantom example
in which now it's clearly visible that
these are two
fluoresce to a nanoparticle
instead of an elongated one so
instead microscopy this means that set
my class we can provide you
um high higher intensity higher standing
so by taking advantage of the simulated
division
addition but also of the um
[Music]
saturation of the processor we can
increase the step beam
in order to having fluorescence only
into the very center of my excitation
volume so we reduce the effective
fluorescent volume
of the microscope and then scanning this
effective fluorescent volume across the
sample we can
end up with very high resolution image
that in principle
is unlimited by increase the star beam i
can reach
high resolution higher resolution so
that's enough let's say theoretically
that's enough but practically there are
some rules that we have to follow
first an important rule that we have to
follow is that we have to
um preserve some special conditions so
we have to be sure that our state beam
is perfectly overlapped with our
excitation beam
another important property that we have
to
that we have to respect to have properly
high resolution imaging
is to preserve the spectral condition
this means that the step being weaving
has to be selected in order to
effectively induce
stimulating emission not other process
let's go a little bit different to this
so we know we represented the molecule
in a very easy way we were two states
with a two-state system but
unfortunately the system is a much
complex uh is much complex so and what
can happen is the step beam is not only
inducing stimulated emission but what
happens that may induce
higher excitation so move the molecule
from the ground state for example from
the higher from
an exciting state to an even higher
excited state of the molecule go to the
triple state to even higher tribal state
so an effort and these states are uh
prone to be
bleached so that's clearly something
that we don't want
so how we can circumvent this problem so
if we know
uh not only the absorption
emission and the absorption
of the molecule spectra of the molecule
but also the emission spectra of the
molecule
and also the transient state absorption
of the molecule
we can move out from the region where
the molecule absorbs when is in the
excited state like in this case for the
gfp which will move from 592 nanometer
to 566
and thereby avoiding the absorption from
one of these states
so but when we move our uh
wavelength of the stack beam we have
also to consider that if we move
we feel if we redshift the stat beam
what we left then
is that we reduce the stimulated
emission cross-section so we need
more power to uh more intensity to
effectively quench the fluorophore
on the other side if we blue shift the
stat beam
so in the direction of the emission of
the molecule
what will happen is that we there is the
chance that we
also excite the molecule we don't
perform we don't induce stimulated
emission
but what we induce is a dioxidation from
uh
from the start beam as depicted in the
diabolos in the others
so there is a solution for that that we
call the things that microscopy i will
go fast on this part because
it's more important the other part of
the talk and as i told you what what can
happen is that
if the extend beam is too close to the
emission
uh spectra like in this case it will
directly excite
the molecule the fluorophore so as you
can see here for example that's a
confocal image of my
phantom 40 nanometer bits that's the
image when i switch on the stat beam so
i expect it to increase the resolution
and effectively you see an increase in
the resolution
but at the same time you see also very
blurred
background that also hide in the
structure of your sample
but since these um
these excitation these fluoresces
induced by the stead beam
i can apply my locking detection
technique to
subtract such a background and that's
exactly what happened in this uh scheme
of this architecture
so if i'm able to induce improv
implement this locking detection
i can remove the background induced by
the stat beam
and end up with a very clear and sharp
steady images
so i can partially solve the problem of
the
of the uh of the background induced by
the
step beam what we call also anti-stocks
emission background
so here is just a recap of all the
literature on this topic
and i suggest you to have a look to this
review if you want to go deeper
on this on this very recent review if
you want to
go deeper on this topic and another
very important uh
condition to satisfy when uh doing when
performing that microscopy
is the temporal condition so it's very
important that the fed beam
photons the stimulating photon
act when the fluorophore are in the
excited state
as i told you it's very important
that since the molecule will stay only
few nanoseconds into the excited state
before
the k for the the excise by emitting
a photon if i want to quench i have to
act
early so i have to come with the cell
beam much early
so um what does it mean is that the
depletion of the fluorescent signal so
how good i'm able to quench the
fluorophore
depends by the number of stimulating
photons to which the 404 is exposed
while exciting the single exciting
states one is into the excited states
since typically fluorophore as in the
range of four nanosecond
uh let's say four nanosecond the excited
states like time
and the cross-section of the stimulated
emission process
is relatively low so we need the
intensity
to let's say saturate the the
the saturated stimulated emission
process
in the range of 10 milliwatts per
centimeter square
and if you want to reach the few tenths
of nanometer resolution
we need to increase even more the
intensity up to gigawatts per centimeter
square
such a value is not surprised if we
compare
two to two photon excitation but it's
clearly higher than we compare when we
compare to one photon excitation
so in further what what happened is that
to reach such kind of intensity
we need pulse scheme so we have to
excite
the the molecule with the pulse laser
and we have to deplete as well
the molecule with another pulse laser
so we need quite a complex scheme
so to solve this so to solve this
problem clearly what we can do we can
use
long life type fluorophore so that means
that now we can if we are able to
increase the the lifetime of the
molecule clearly we have more time to
induce stimulated emissions
but we can reduce the intensity but it's
not easy to engineering
organic fluorophore or protein with such
a long lifetime fluorophore so that's
clearly not
an easy solution another solution is
represented by the sand gating
so what is tam gating so basically the
idea of tangate is that
is that we want to register the
fluorescent cilia
only after time tg after fixed time
from the fluorescent excitation event so
we excite the molecule
we wait for a certain time and then we
start to record the
uh the floor for the fluorescent in such
a way
what will happen is that the signal that
we record
will come only for fluorophore that have
reside to the exciting state
at least for a time tg so that has c
stimulated photons at least for this
time so we can somehow prolongate the
effective floor
and effective lifetime of the
fluorophore so that's the principle of
getting started microscopy let's go
deeper
in this to better understand why we can
let's say um reduce the
the intensity by use the intensity of
the study by
using time gating detection so this
figure
represents the fluorescence lifestyle
they represent the temporal response
the temperatures behavior all the
fluorescent from an excited molecule so
if the molecule is
excited the time zero so it will decay
following
this sort of exponential function
if we shine also instead the
step lies on the same molecule so what
will happen is that the molecule will
decay
much faster as you can see from this red
light
higher is the intensity of the stud beam
faster will decay
this faster will be the decay of the
fluorescence
so that simply comes by the fact that
now we
by stimulated emission depletion we open
a new dexcitation pathway on the
molecule and in particular this means
that the lifetime of the molecule
will become much shorter so that's the
question that describes the lifetime of
the molecule that is one over the rate
of spontaneous emission
plus the rate of stimulated emission
higher is the rate of estimated
emissions
faster is the decay but there is if you
see
this graph here also note that
at the time zero there is almost no
difference from the
the probability there is no different
the probability of the molecule to
fluorescence
but the probability of fluorescence
become much much much more different
when the time spam
across this dimension so in particular
what will happen that
after center time there is a huge
difference between
the absence of stimulated emission or
the presence of stimulated image so that
means that if we record
the fluorescence after for example
a time tg that is in the order of
nanosecond in this case is one
nanosecond
now the probability that the molecule
fluoresces
is much less that the probability that
the molecule
emits the problem that we record
a photon a fluorescent photo from this
molecule will substantially
reduce so as you can see now our
depletion curve
will be enhanced so if we need 80
millibit
milliwatts per centimeter square to
quench at a few percent now
the molecule now we need only 40
millimeter
milliwatts per centimeter square to
reduce almost to zero the probability to
uh
of fluorescence so if we even increase
more the intensity
we even increase more the time delay
high we improve even further the
depletion
so now we have clearly a way to enhance
the probability to quench a fluorophore
without increasing the intensity of the
study so that's an example on
a on a
on a real sample that's a nano crystal
as you can see by increasing the
intensity of the stat being what we left
and
is that we we
change the lifetime of the molecule
become shorter and shorter
but what is more important that if we
apply time getting so for example we
collect the light after five nanoseconds
we
induce we increase the uh the depletion
curve so we make
we reduce the probability to collect the
fluorophore
and thereby we we we can somehow reduce
the intensity of the
uh of the step beam so what does it mean
this in terms of resolution so
here now we are back to the conventional
scheme of
of of a microscope so we have a gaussian
excitation and we have our
uh donut step beam if we collect
the light after a time dg what will
happen is that
the effective fluorescent volume will
reduce as you can see from the red
to the green so one important aspect
that now we are dealing also with
continuous weight
laser for the step beam so we are also
reducing the complexity
of the microscope so that's an example
again on an
on a real sample so that's a single
particle in particular is
an empty center so as you notice
here is the confocal images that is
roughly that one nanometer that we
expected by this action
when we switch off which on the step
being we enact the resolution now it's
much smaller
and when we apply tangatine so we
collect light after a few nanoseconds in
this case after five nanoseconds from
the excitation event
we further reduce the effective
fluorescent volume
and in particular the function function
of the system and the bioware enhance
the resolution
by simply play with a targeting so
without
increasing the intensity of the study so
that's
maybe a recap of what i told you before
so
you know that instead my classmates i
told you before we can
increase the intensity we can increase
the resolution by increasing the
intensity of the steady beam
but now we have a second pathway to
increase the resolution of the step
microscope
that is by delay the recording of the
fluorescence is by implementing
targeting
as you can see here if we maintain the
same steady intensity but we delay
the recording then the resolution
improve
here there is the equation so now we we
can improve the resolution by increasing
the interest of the standing or we can
increase the resolution by
delay the the the the the delay the
the the recording of the fluorescence we
are targeting so that's an example
of the of this technique on a on a real
sample
so as you notice the first image is the
confocal
then when we shine the stat beam then
there is an enhancement
resolution but a further enhancement of
resolution is obtained when we apply
sign gating
without increasing the intensity of the
stat beam
here at the tail and you can clearly see
how much easiest to resolve the tubulin
structure into the sample confoca
continuously step and create it stand
so we can somehow improve the resolution
without increasing the step bit
but what's more important is that we can
achieve a certain resolution
by using much less power so we can
increase the photo stability of
our system so we can reduce the
bleaching of our microscope
so that's particularly useful not only
in terms of photobeating but also in
terms of phototoxicity so thanks to this
time getting implementation
for the first time we can record live
cell imaging like in this example as you
when you compare confocal to get instead
of
and we record the diffusion of a gfp
label
vesicle that are moving along an action
of drosophila larva
so thanks to lekka and to sigris for
giving us the opportunity to show this
this data
and i will keep the part
of the application of get it into pulse
system but clearly you can get the same
benefit also in past
uh in in pulse instead for the same
for the same reason so what does it mean
that nowaday
we thanks also to tangating we can use
much less complex laser such for example
the sub
nanosecond fiber laser instead of very
complex architecture like in the early
implementation of stead microscopy
this is an example in which again we
show
that that's the confocal here is the
gate
is the the the stud image again in a
tubulin sample
and that's in that's the the the
improvement that we obtained
by using it instead on a pulse
architecture
in a past architecture the main reason
to use in a parse architecture
is the fact that now we can again
reduce the intensity of of the stack
beam simply because now we can
spread the photon across at a relatively
long path in the order of let's say one
nanosecond
without losing in resolution but
improving the photostability of the
fluorophore
now the bleaching reduce much due to the
fact that i can decrease the intensity
of the study
and another way to explain it is that
microscopy to explain
why it's important to perform time
resolved
stead microscopy is um approaching this
from
from the point of view of the the
lifetime so as i told you before
what we what we have is that when we
increase when we
shine a stat beam on a molecule we
modify
the effective excited state of the
molecule and in particular
higher is the intensity of the stud beam
shorter
is the lifetime of of the molecule so
faster is the mission of the photon if
the steel of a spontaneous photo of a
fluorescence
if it is of course so that means that
since
our stat beam as a special signature so
in particular
the intensity is very high into the
crester into the crest and
zero into the center what will happen is
that we will induce
a special signature into the exciting
state
into the lifetime of the fluorophore and
in particular what will happen as you
can see
here but also from this graph graph
is that if the molecule is into the
center
then we will have it will have a and
a shorter a shorter a longer lifetime
when the molecule is moving into the
periphery when the molecule
is into the periphery of the excitation
volume what will happen is that the
lifetime becomes shorter
so molecular into the periphery will be
characterized by a shorter lifetime
molecule to the center will be
characterized by a longer lifetime
so that means that if we apply time
gating so if we collect the flora of
fluorescence only after same certain uh
time so we will collect the floor of
fluorescence coming only from the long
lifetime molecule so the molecules that
are
into the center of the into the center
of the excitation volume so
here is the same example that i showed
before but depicting
also the lifetime of the molecule so as
you can see here
the molecule when is into the center of
the excitation
volume it has a longer lifetime that's
an in the center so it's a roughly
40 nanoseconds but when is into the
periphery the
the lifetime become much shorter go up
to
a few hundredths of picosecond that is
depicted here in blue
so if we apply time gating so that means
that we select the photo
that are coming only from the center of
the
of the detection volume but there is a
big problem in the targeting
implementation
unfortunately when we apply sand gating
we do not discard
only photons that are into the periphery
and thereby the photo that effectively
we don't want
but also photon that are coming from the
center of your
positive function of of your detection
volume
of the of the microscope so that means
that the finite noise ratio of
your image drastically decrease as you
can see here
when we apply time gating and further
the peak intensity change from 190
photon
counts per fraction of 110 of
milliseconds
down to 40 uh only 40 photons
so that means that if you have a dim
sample or if you have a background in
your
in your uh in your system then
unfortunately you will end up with
an image that is pretty noisy and then
you can not clearly
distinguish any fuse feature in that so
how we can solve this problem
so that's that's what we um that's what
we
that's why we start to uh implement
not another approach like in the time
gating that is very straightforward
approach
by the computational approach that is we
call separation by lifetime tuning
so to understand this approach i need a
little bit of math no
not very complex one but i need to
introduce a couple of functions so
first of all as i told you before um
thanks to the stead to the stead uh to
the stimulating emission phenomena
to the fact that i'm using a
donor-shaped step beam
i can induce a special signature into
the
lifetime of the molecule so in
particular if i have a single molecule
that is located at the distance air from
the center of my detection volume
the fluorescence signal emitted by by
this molecule can be described by this
function
so that is an exponential function
in which the uh the rate of the
exponential is given by the lifetime of
of the molecule and the lifetime of the
molecule as i told you
is is a direct
is modified by the the stat beam so
let's assume that and again another
important thing is that there is a
parameter that is
given by the excitation of the uh where
the
depend again by the position and is how
strong i
excite the molecule but that's let's say
is um let's say is
a multiplicative element now let's one
step further let's think that we have
two molecules so
a different distance from the center so
what will happen to my fluorescence
recorded by the detection volume
is that it's simply represented by the
sum of the two
fluorescence from the two molecule one
in the outer part of the
of the detection volume the other one
the inner part of the detection volume
let's make one step further so let's now
assume that we have more than two
molecule
and in part but that we have all the
molecule in two consenting rings
one inner ring and the in another outer
ring so in the reality this will not
happen but
we demonstrate that making this
assumption will not change significantly
the results without introducing too much
complexity in the problem that we will
solve
so if we have such a condition so the
fluorescence signal
it can be described by the sum again of
two components
in which we make a further step and we
use the normalized
exponential function so we are the first
fraction
that is given by the photon coming from
the inner part
of my detection volume and the second
fraction that is coming from the
outer part of my detection volume
very important these are linear
independently so
clearly the problem what we would like
to have in a
twin to enhance the resolution is to
collect
only the fluorophore only solid only the
the fluorescence coming from this part
from the inner molecule so one can think
to make a fitting
of this function and extract only this
component but there is a much
easy way to do that that does not need
any modeling of these two functions does
not need to
know that these are exponential
functions first
so that is to represent this signal into
the phasor plot
so a phasor plot allow me to take a
temporal signal like in these cases
through transforming a simple two value
because what we calculate is the cosine
and sine transform of mycenae and we end
up with a simple
two value with a simple point into the
so-called
phasor plot one of the beauty of the
phasor plot representation
is that if we have a linear combination
of signal like in this case
we end up with a super imposition of
vector
in the phasor representation so that
means that now
my phasor will be simply the weighted
sum
of two phasor other phasor points that
represent
the function
of the inner fluorescence
and the function representing the
outer fluorophore so
this kind of system can be easily
inverted in a very fast way by simply
solving
a two um it's a two variable
linear system and what we can we can
extract
very fast and very easily are they only
the signing coming from the inner part
of my detection volume
so that means that compared to the
targeted implementation we are not
discarding photon coming from the center
of my detection volume
but we are simply separating this photo
in order to generate my high resolution
images
another very important and nice property
of the phasor plot is that is they also
to take advantage
of that is able to separate the
background
for example a background the
uncorrelated background for example the
background that is coming from the
excitation
of the stud being since this background
is uncorrelated
respect to the variable t so it's
constant respect to the the temporal
dimension
so what we learned is that it will be
represented as a point
in the zero in the center of the polar
coordinate and again by simply math
we can extract the three component
the inner part the housing part and the
background
and end up with a system that is say
with a technique that is able to isolate
all the fluorophore coming from the
center
and also not um induced by the the
by this distant beam under by not not
background photon
so now the question is how we can
effectively implement this approach to
effectively implement this approach what
we need
simply to know is the phasor that is the
phasor of the
inner component and the phasor of the
outer component
but that's relatively easy because the
phasor of the inner
component is simply given by the
confocal counterpart
and in this case since in most of the
cases a single exponential decay
you will rely into the semi universal
semicircle
when we that's also important to
visualize
this graph because here we show that we
when we're increasing
the intensity of the staging so we move
along this direction you can clearly see
that the phasor plot
is moving towards this direction because
the lifetime of the follicle
becomes much much much shorter so as i
told you before we don't need
only the the the representation of the
phases for the inner part
but we need also the the phases for the
outer part
in this case we found out that the best
solution
is to take the the as a function
corresponding to the
to the the phasor in the outer part an
exponential decay
of the molecule into the donut crest so
that means that it is very easy to
extract from from
experiment these two value when we have
these two values then we can simply
decompose
our for each pixel of our in
images the the phasor plot in the two
components
and highlight all all we obviously only
the inner part
so as you can see for example from this
example
so here it's again an example of
imaging of tubulin in a confocal
modality
here is the phasor plot representation
that means that for each pixel we
calculate
the phasor representation and we should
lie on the semicircle but since there is
a sort of cell quenching
is slightly shifted from the semicircle
but that's the phase of cloth
representation of the confocus so that
will be let's say
the phasor for our and for our
uh inner um for our
inner uh photon when we activate the
step beam as you can see there is
a huge shift of the phasor plot that is
moving
towards the short lifetime
because as i told you when we do
stimulated emission we start to
shift the molecule towards a shorter
lifetime
especially the one into the periphery
and also there is an in
a background that is represented by this
point and as you see the phasor is also
moving toward the background
but what we can do now by simply solving
for each pixel a linear equation
we can separate the photon from the
inner part
as you can see here from the outer part
and from the background and we end up
with a much
higher resolution image in particular
when we compare with the gating
as i told you before the gating is
wonderful when you have
high synaption but such in this case
in which we have a pretty strong
background as you can see here
there is no a huge enhancement
resolution but only when we separate the
photon from the inner part
from the outer part and from the
background we end up with a very high
resolution image
so here i just show you how by a
computational approach
we can get the same benefit of time
gating by solving the problem of the
signal duration
and also by naturally removing the
background so we have another way
to increase the resolution of the study
microscope without
increasing the intensity of the step
beam and thereby without increasing the
phototoxicity
and making it really suitable for
lifestyle imaging
so again like for the time negating
this this approach the split approach
can be
um extended to uh past implementation
also because the beauty of
the split approach doesn't need a model
so for example in the case of
pulse pass ted implementation we don't
have any more
at the cake that follows exponential
behavior but we have
we have much more complex function so
with this
i would like to finish and but i would
like to
thank all my group at the italian
institute of technology and in
particular the molecular microscopy
group further i would like to thank
people from the
nanoscopy group in particular alberta
diaspora paolo bianchini and luca
lantana
luca lanzano was the guy that developed
with me the
the street approach the last part of the
talk then
i would like to talk people from the
polytechnic of milan for
uh developing special detector for the
targeting implementation
then i don't want to forget the people
people from my previous group and in
particular from the max planck
clearly stefanel anderson munero
and and then christian aguilene from now
at oxford university
and finally a very big thanks to like a
microsystem that gives me
a chance to rack up a little bit these
10 years of
of research so thanks to all of you for
your attention
dr vijay domini thank you so much for
your informative presentation that was a
lot of information to take in now to our
audience
it is now time for our live q a now if
you have a question you would like to
ask
please do so now simply type them into
the ask a question box
and click send we will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for
now it looks like we have time for just
a few questions
dr victor domini let's start with this
one if there is a requirement
to increase the power of stead beam for
more resolution
then helps the photo bleaching
controlled
okay so uh first once again
people organize this webinar and before
i apply to this question i just would
like to i like the fact that
you can find my email into any slide
of my presentation and i will be happy
to
get all your questions also by email and
reply
one by one and also maybe to chat with
you um
concerning the last question the
question that uh
i got it so um photo bleaching is
uh and not only photography is one of
the
big somehow uh limitation especially
in the the heavily implementation of
that microscopy
so increasing the skin power for sure
will increase photovoltaic specificity
but i want to see that a lot of
development here i just present this
time resolved
approach allowed to reduce the intensity
of the stat beam so
nowaday there's not really any more
problems that can be really
applied to to live cell so a new probe
has been developed
new very sensitive detector has been
developed new laser has been developed
and thereby if if 10 years ago
photo bleaching photography was a
problem instead
now that's not anymore
very good thank you our next question as
the stead beam is not perfectly zero
in the center how much shorter do you
expect the good fluorescence lifetime to
decrease
okay yeah that's that's another um let's
say technical aspect so
uh pretty easily uh will be great if the
the
the second zero donut is
zero like the name but that's not
happening especially when you have
uh absorption or we are about in
position that are far away from october
when you go deeper and so on
um again that's that's a problem because
you quench fluorophore into the center
and that you cannot do nothing
it's a problem also for uh for this time
resolved approaches because you change
the lifetime motion to the center
but for example in split you can take
into into account about this problem
into the mode into the into the
algorithm
and and somehow complaining for this
aspect so
uh just to resume the best will be to
remove
and to correct for the aberration that
reduce your
zero intensity quality but on the other
side by computation you can somehow
overcome also the biggest problem
dr vijay domini how are how are long
lifetime fluorophores produced
okay um that's uh that's that's what
okay the dream will be to have a very
long lifetime
florida uh because in this case uh
let's say that the need of uh intensity
uh steady intensity will reduce uh
clearly it's possible to engineering
and maybe not organic fluorophore for
this but there are some particles for
example in the center as a
tenth 10 nanometer lifetime i know that
other nano crystal can have much longer
but we have to keep in mind that we want
to make this technique readily be used
for
for for life science so um
i guess that at the moment does not make
so much sense developed to use
um some some probes to develop
some some let's say some uh
inorganic flora for that with long
lifetime that then
cannot use for really bioapplication
so um that means that organic 404 has
four nanosecond lifetime that is already
pretty good
so i don't think that that may be one of
the most important direction for
for the developed instant microscopy so
i think that it's much more
important to optimize uh the the current
floral core to make them more
photostable and thereby to
to react better to more light
dr peter domini how dependent is the
split stead effect
on the particular dye and are certain
dyes more useful
than others um okay
so um let's say the again
longer is the lifetime better it is but
that's uh that's um that's a general uh
uh um that's a general technique so any
fluorophore is fine for strip step
the beauty of split step that gives you
a very big enhancement in a region in
which you do not use
a very a very high intensity set beam
so that's the most uh important part of
street fighter
i i can i can say
thank you dr vijay nominee now we have
time for one more question
but i do want to remind our audience one
more time that
all those questions we are unable to
answer today and any of those questions
that come in during the on-demand period
dr vichy domini will be answering those
via the email address you provided at
the time of registration
dr futur domini is split stead
particularly good
for strong background as compared to
time-gated stead
um i think that that that's the basic um
the most important difference between uh
split stead
and get it ted um at least
in the in the version that i show you um
speedstead it's perfectly able to remove
background and use by the stat beam
because
as i show you is a sort of uncorrelated
background
um that's in principle can be also
implemented in
in time get instead but uh i can say
that that's
the result that we already that we see
um during our for in our experiences
that split step work work better
so as i told you also time gating can be
combined with the convolution and
thereby with other method with
computational methods
to make the quality of the image better
so the beauty of please fed
is that it's a very straightforward
approach
no many um input
no almost no input from the user are
needed
while maybe in the conclusion you need a
little bit to be clear about
some parameter so that's also why i
think that uh
leica as far as they know is going also
a little bit in this direction
so to implement in the machine similar
similar approaches
so that's why i'm pretty confident that
uh we will uh i'm sure that this this
street stand
uh method will be uh implemented almost
in any in any microscope so
and that's why i like also to thanks all
mike again my collaborator and
particular local entrepreneur that
is the let's say the first author of of
of the paper that introduced the
speedster
i can see really a bright future for for
this implementation
dr vito domini thank you so much for
your time today and for your important
research
i would also like to thank labyrinth and
our sponsor leica microsystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and we hope to see you again soon
have a great day have a great day
bye thanks a lot thank you
bye
you